[Musique]
cis que vous faites un pardon j'étais en
train vont fumer alors c'est quoi ce
bond sur le siège arrière
c'est marrant mais c'est une sculpture
que j'ai fait à l'école je ne sais pas
quoi vous pensiez vous conduisiez avec
un bond dans votre voiture vous vous
prenez pour tes douillet nelson et même
lui s'est fait arrêter le temps a la
fâcheuse habitude d'être éphémère
ma mère mais chris a dans une lettre
quand j'avais 8 ans ok je me vidais
il reste que deux semaines ensemble au
lycée l'homme voici triste cran comment
on va faire avec la beuh l'année
prochaine cinq ans va cela ferrat la
cool avec la drogue d'un hiver maussade
il obtient on a toujours été à l'école
ensemble
l'idée c'est qu'on reste à côté les unes
des autres clés le chef vient le moment
tu te rends compte que tu seras pas une
sportive professionnelle
tu es un peu ça ce soir et bien ce
moment dont tu parles ils arrivent un
peu plus tard chez les blacks mais toi
d'où tu as fais ce que tu veux dire
c'est le silo à l'université de new york
et moi l'université columbia on est niée
pour l'aide en fait je suis même pas sûr
à 100 % de ce que je vais faire ce que
je veux maintenant je veux mes potes
[ __ ] ou les lignes c1 je voudrais bien
savoir où est le manque nos planches de
service
[Musique]
tendre qui étaient avec nous pendant
lycée la ville un global et ses examens
ça restera toujours une t'aimons abi
pour les gens du secteur a flippé quand
les choses vont s'arrêter 17 jérémy
quand tu es devenu malin toi suis
entouré de femmes exceptionnelles
lille tu ne devrais pas être dans ma
classe maintenant et vous ne devriez
être dans votre classe matin cette
conversation n'a pas eu les mêmes